قد لا تبدو المدينه هذه المزدحمه بالسكان
قادره على استيعاب المزيد من الناس ولا
سكانها انفسهم قادرين على دفع تكاليف
السكن فالاسر الفقيره هنا وخاصه للنازحه
اتخذت من هذه الدكاكين مسكنا لها بعد رفع
ملاك العقارات اجور الشقق السكنيه في تعز
الى اكثر من مئه في المئه
الدقون على قدر على قدر حالي اما الشقه ما
اقدرش استاجر شقه ابدا نهائيا لان الوضع
اننا اداره ارتفعوا الاسعار احنا ما نقدرش
150 150 180 الايجار حق الشقق نجحنا سبعه
بل هذا الدكان والله ان احنا ما يساحنه
ولا حاجه من احنا سبعه بنتي شباب بسبب ان
احنا ما نقدر نستاجر شقه ليست هذه الاسره
وحدها من اضطرت للعيش في مكان يفتقر
لنافذه واحده بل هناك العشرات من الاسر
واجهه المصير ذاته بعد ارتفاع اجور الشقق
السكنيه الى 150 الف ريال للشهر الواحد
اوضع ماساويه صعبه تعيشها هذه الاسر في
اماكن اشبهه بالسجون مع ترد الوضع المعيشي
وانقطاع الرواتب وتراجع فرص العمل في
البلد
كامل نعرض المتر
والله ما يكبحين نتدايق
على حسب الظروف حاولنا جاهدين على ان نقنن
هذه المساله وقلنا يجب ان يرفع
بالجانب المنطقي وهو عشره في المئه الى
عشرين في المئه اما ان يرفع 200 الى 300%
فهذا شيء غير مقبول هكذا اذا بدا مسكن
الاسر الفقيره في المدينه هذه وهكذا بدا
حالهم مع ارتفاع اجور السكن امر دفع بعض
الاسر الى مغادره المدينه التي تفتقر الى
اليات تنظم الاجوره بين المواطن وملاك
العقارات
الى اكثر من مئه في المئه اذا ارتفعت اجور
العقارات والشقق السكنيه داخل محافظه تعز
وهو من عكس سلبا على الحياه المعيشيه
للمواطن اليمني لكن الجهات الحكوميه تحاول
جاهده الحد من هذه الاشكاليه هل سعيد
العربيه تعز